alors d'abord monsieur le rapporteur sur
le choix de l'appel à projet il y a un
échange entre mon directeur de cabinet
Monsieur le Préfet j'allais et moi-même
sur la manière justement de financer et
de soutenir financièrement au mieux les
acteurs de la société civile Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais me propose de passer par
un appel à projet en me disant tout à
fait conscient qu'aujourd'hui ça peut
paraître paradoxal à la lumière des
événements mais en disant que ce sera
plus transparent et plus équitable que
les subventions de gré à gré puisque
jusqu'à présent c'était des subventions
me semble-t-il de gré à gré du cipdr en
direction des associations nous avons
alors le sentiment que l'appel à projet
répond effectivement à cette demande
d'une part d'autre part qui permettra de
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs qui
sont pas forcément encore
identifiés dans la sphère du cpdr et
donc nous prenons ensemble et j'assume
la décision de passer par un appel à
projet
ensuite il y a un comité de sélection
qui est mise en place avec des membres
de l'administration et des membres de
mon cabinet moi je n'interviens pas
personnellement je ne suis pas dans le
comité de sélection eu égard ce que je
rappelais dans mon propos introductif
les rôles de chacun mais pas du rôle du
ministre de faire de l'hymne générique
et d'ouvrir le capot pour regarder
l'ensemble des dossiers donc je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection en
revanche je suis tenue bien sûr informé
régulièrement par mon cabinet des
discussions qui peuvent exister autour
de l'attribution des subventions
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais à ma connaissance
vous deviez faire partie du comité de
sélection
je n'en ai pas souvenir je n'ai pas de
trace dans mes éléments du fait que je
dois en faire partie en tout cas je n'en
fais pas partie c'est une observation
que je porte à la connaissance de chacun
je relève dans l'explication que vous
venez de donner que vous avez vous dites
avoir suivi des conseils du préfet
Jallet votre directeur de cabinet à
l'époque
et vous dites pour l'appel à projet
étant conseiller comme une procédure
plus transparente et plus équitable je
mesure que vous utilisez à dessin ces
mots puisque ce sont exactement les
mêmes qui sont repris par l'Inspection
générale de l'administration pour
dénoncer le fait que la procédure était
ni transparente ni équitable donc je ne
sais pas si c'est un une manière pour
vous de répondre et de dire que il y a
eu erreur sur toute la ligne je sais pas
si vous voulez
aller un peu plus loin sur le sujet
parce que si vous démarrez vos propos en
expliquant que ce qui devait être plus
juste plus transparent et plus équitable
ne l'est pas de votre propre aveu enfin
déclaration et donc aveu c'est un c'est
une déclaration me semble-t-il
importante que vous faites à cet instant
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit d'abord moi
je n'ai pas d'appréciation à porter sur
le rapport de l'hygia c'est un rapport
qui a été mené avec le plus grand
sérieux par une inspection qui est
réputée pour son professionnalisme qui a
eu accès à des informations auxquelles
moi je n'ai pas accès puisque une fois
encore je ne suis pas omniscient dans ce
dossier j'étais ministre dans un temps
donné dans un temps limité je n'ai pas
interrogé les différents acteurs c'est
l'hygia qui a réalisé ce travail mais je
n'ai aucune raison de de contester la
conclusion de l'Hégire et je n'ai non
plus je me parais de reprendre votre
terme sur la porte aucun aveu à faire
dans la mesure où je n'ai pas pris à ce
comité pas pris part pardon à ce comité
de sélection
d'accord